this is some juice right here yeah
twitch sued for 25 million dollars over
suggestive content okay one man Eric
hasta vo is now suing twitch for a
million dollars after he says that the
streaming platform exposed him to
suggestive content this individual is
not new to lawsuits lawsuits against
giant companies having recently been
involved in efforts to sue Microsoft
Sony Nintendo and Blizzard according to
the lawsuit documents that we have
obtained esta vo gives a laundry list of
female-only streamers that he is blaming
for exacerbating his sex addiction
due to his obsessive compulsive disorder
and saying that it is impossible to use
the service without being exposed to
such content disorder he has to
masturbate not same thing is a is a
mental disorder no it dude it's it's not
it's not even that it's it's it's just a
function of a certain level of IQ it's
just it's it's it's input/output I see
woman I masturbate there's no there's no
in-between bro that is so funny to go on
Twitch and to be like I really hope it's
no women on the front page today yeah
yeah come on come on come on come on and
then illinit ii listen okay here we'll
just i'll read this a little bit more
and then i'm gonna provide a
counterpoint in defense of this man all
right Oh better be steaming hot there be
solid bulletproof I gotta hear this
according to the suit s2 vo is following
786 female streamers and zero mail
stream argues that the site doesn't
offer a way to filter streamers by
gender therefore he is forced to choose
a game and/or category to watch with
thumbnails showing these scantily clad
women right he's just trying to prove a
point to his wife honey it's not my
fault and I'll prove it to you I'll I'll
sue them
look at here look at here look at my
following list zero males do you see a
single male on there exactly it's not
much it's not my fault it's just there's
no way for me to filter what else am I
supposed to do
here's the thing this guy could be
seriously mentally ill I mean yeah OCD
is a nasty one like he could be I mean
he could have some serious issues right
and the thing is if he enjoys watching
twitch and he enjoys watching people
play video games and just adding at
whatever yeah and he he really doesn't
have the option to hide the females
right okay that's resin if you go on you
might be thinking well then don't go on
the Internet right but you can use porn
blockers and you can use a object
objectionable yeah these filters use
filters filters yeah right
you could make the internet like a safer
place for you if you had like such a
yeah mental disorder like this yeah
brother you can't
there must be wild if like when he goes
to watch twitch he has to like bolt his
hands in like he has to sit like in like
a pseudo electric chair yes like his
wrists have to be tied down and the
mouse you know you know what I mean and
he's yeah okay that's not gonna happen
today I'm not I'm not gonna give in
today yeah I will not give I will not
spank off I will just watch them dance
and do nothing bro this is this is crazy
man
I'm yes I'd like to sue twitch because
um I had they're making me horny that is
man oh man and you know what dude with
how old judges are I could easily see
him winning yeah yeah just to stick it
to the old nasty tech company yeah you
know your shirt offer a way where people
children want to be on this platform and
it's not right that you have boobs on
the front page the thing is don't they
don't they ban people now like women for
for wearing I don't know like revealing
shirts and stuff or now I thought that
date that's something that they did just
if they don't want any sexual content at
all or do they depends on your
relationship with twins right right
right so they play favorites right they
definitely play favorites okay yeah you
know like you and I could never right we
don't we don't have we don't have supple
enough we don't have be a beautiful
bosom to to gaze at but if you were
blessed of the sorry go ahead
if you were blessed with a beautiful
bosom you may have a few mods or two
that say well let's not get crazy right
right but we need a sweet set of moves
yeah sweet moves okay we need like a
sweet supple set of moves yeah don't get
a [ __ ] up this is not just female
bosom this is there is male bosom in
2020 yeah yeah magnificent moobs
yeah magnet who's that we're gonna start
that category on pornhub magnificent
moves and it's just gamers with moobs
playing shirtless then we can expect
plenty of lawsuits for people who can't
stop jerking off to that cuz that sounds
hot copious amounts of women I just
would like to go down pornhub and
consume
erotic novel type content and I just
keep getting waterboarded with males
playing World of Warcraft and I can't
not masturbate to their beautiful moobs
[Laughter]
there we should legit sue sue pornhub
for what for making making people horny
[Laughter]
you